liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
an alle hier im saal an diejenigen die
uns im live stream verfolgen
wir werden auch in diesen zeiten oder
besonders in diesen zeiten live
übertragen auf dem sender phoenix
begleitet von
gebärdensprachdolmetscherin wie herzlich
willkommen dank an phoenix dieses
gewährleisten
ich möchte zuvorderst unsere gäste
begrüßen bundesgesundheitsminister jedem
sparen der präsident des robert
koch-instituts bewässert auf der leader
und heute mit dabei dr ralf franke der
leiter des gesundheits management 7 ich
habe mich willkommen schön dass sie
unsere gäste heute sind wir sprechen
heute über die betriebsärzte und die
impfkampagne erster linie danach sind
ihre fragen herzlich willkommen
wir halten das wie immer in diesen
zeiten zuerst eine frage eine nachfrage
wenn es die kapazitäten zu lassen
nämlich sie gerne wieder auf die liste
und wir begrenzen
diese pressekonferenz auch mit blick auf
eine folgende auf eine stunde und eine
bewertung noch zu unserer organisation
für diejenigen die uns noch nicht kennen
für alle die schon öfter hier waren
ihnen werden diese sätze bekannt sein
die bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation von
journalistinnen und journalisten die
bundespolitik berichten wir hängen also
entgegen mancher annahme nicht mit der
regierung zusammen und damit über gebe
ich jetzt das wort an
gesundheitsminister jens spahn bitte
sehr liebe frau wolff meine damen und
herren die impfkampagne geht mit großen
schritten weiter voran stand heute
morgen ist mehr als jeder zweite
deutsche mindestens einmal geimpft 50,1
prozent das sind 41 5 millionen menschen
jeder dieser 41,5 millionen schützt sich
und andere und jeder und jeder dieser
41,5 millionen hilft die pandemie besser
in den griff zu bekommen sind sogar
leicht mehr als 41,5 millionen exakt
50,1 prozent 29,6 prozent haben den
vollen impfschutz das ist fast jeder
dritte
und das sind zwei wichtige meilensteine
für deutschland für unsere impfkampagne
aber das heißt gleichzeitig auch das
tempo weiter hoch halten weil wir
natürlich weitermachen wollen bis alle
geschützt sind
diese zahlen machen zuversichtlich zumal
wenn wir die perspektive auch für die
nächsten wochen betrachten innerhalb
weniger wochen wird es stand heute mit
den lieferungen die wir erwarten dürfen
möglich sein alle impfwilligen
erwachsenen auch ein impfangebot zu
machen allein von den mma impfstoffen
vom biontech und moderner sind so viele
lieferungen bis ende juli zugesagt dass
wir bestand heute wenn nichts
unerwartetes passiert diese prognose
werden halten können
das heißt wir kommen in eine zeit in der
es sehr darauf ankommen wird all
diejenigen die vielleicht noch zweifeln
die zögern die noch überlegen denen die
hürde einen termin beim arzt oder im ins
zentrum zu machen zu hoch ist zu
überzeugen und sie zu erreichen
und da kommt die betriebsärzte ins spiel
und ärztinnen natürlich auch denn sie
holen die menschen am arbeitsplatz ab im
alltag da ist die gute gelegenheit das
beste argument sich impfen zu lassen
wenn der kollege die kollegin zum impfen
geht oder vielleicht sogar das ganze
team dann zusammen geht dann kann keiner
eben mehr behaupten das sei ihm zu
aufwendig deshalb freut es mich dass dr
franke leiter des gesundheitsmanagements
bei siemens uns heute auch aus diesen
erfahrungen den ersten berichten wird
seit dem 17 juni wie sie wissen sind die
betriebsärztin und betriebsärzte
regelhaft teil unserer impfkampagne
zwischen fünf und 6000 betriebsärztin
und betriebsärzte impfen jede woche mit
im moment sind es um die 700.000
impfdosen pro woche ich weiß sie könnten
auch noch mehr aber das gilt in allen
bereichen aber jetzt ist jedenfalls
wichtig dass wir auch dort begonnen
haben
niedrigschwellig und effektiv das ist
auch deshalb wichtig weil wir uns von
neuen virus varianten wappnen und
schützen müssen
die delta variante
breitet sich inzwischen auch in
deutschland aus der villa wird leicht
die aktuellen zahlen dazu auch noch mal
sagen und einordnen können
wichtig ist es ist auf niedrigem niveau
aber eben schnell und wir haben gerade
in den letzten zwei drei wochen eine
relativ starke steigerung gesehen
die herausforderung ist dass dieses
diese virus variante besonders
ansteckend ist und sie eben auch dazu
fortführen kann
erfolge in der pandemie bekämpfung
wieder infrage zu stellen das erlebt
gerade sehr leidvoll das vereinigte
königreich das in vielen bereichen ja
auch schon sehr gute entwicklung hatte
und auch in weiten teilen noch immer hat
dabei gleichzeitig eben etwa auch
weitere öffnung schritte hat verschieben
müssen wegen der aktuellen entwicklung
und das wollen wir vermeiden
delta breitet sich die variante delta im
vereinigten königreich auch vor allem
bei jüngeren aus und schwere verläufe
sind insbesondere zu beobachten bei
nicht geimpften und durchaus auch bei
denjenigen die nur eine impfung erhalten
haben
das zeigt das was wir ja schon seit
wochen sagen die zweite impfung ist
wichtig und unsere strategie die zweite
impfung auch innerhalb des vorgesehenen
intervalls zeitlichen intervalls
vorzunehmen geht dann in diese richtung
auch richtig auf das heißt gleichzeitig
auch neben dem impfen und den
fortschritten der impfkampagne weiterhin
vorsichtig bleiben
ich habe hier schon zwei oder drei mal
gesagt das kann ein guter sommer werden
das gilt auch weiterhin wir haben anlass
zu zuversicht aber eben vor allem dann
wenn wir dabei auch vorsichtig bleiben
die masten seine diskussion dieser woche
können bei diesen guten wetter vor allem
draußen auch fallen und weg bleiben aber
da wo in innenräumen oder auch in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
zumal dann wenn man mit menschen die man
nicht kennt wo man auch nicht weiß ob
geimpft oder gelesen oder auch
tagesaktuell getestet man in einem raum
ist miteinander dann im zweifel die
maske weiterhin tragen um sich und
andere gerade auch mit blick auf die
variante zu schützen
auch das testen bleibt wichtig die
flächendeckende infrastruktur die wir
mit hohem tempo aufgebaut haben wollen
wir auch über den sommer
vorhalten das ist ein beschluss der
gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister der länder bund und
länder und auch die kommunen im übrigen
wenn sie die kommunalen spitzenverbände
nehmen haben noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen auch auf unserer
gesundheitsministerkonferenz am mittwoch
in münchen wie wichtig es ist dass wir
das testangebot gerade auch in der
reisezeit aufrechterhalten
wir haben alle noch die letzten
sommerreise zeiten durchaus in den
knochen man sich gelegentlich noch mal
daran erinnern damals gab es keine
schnelltests zumindest nicht in
ausreichender qualität und verfügbarkeit
und unsere pcr-test kapazitäten pro
woche waren bei einigen hunderttausend
mittlerweile haben wir test kapazitäten
pcr von 3.000.000 die woche und viele
viele millionen schnelltests zur
verfügung und auch selbst testen gemacht
werden können und das soll dann eben
auch genutzt werden können und bitte
auch genutzt werden
von reiserückkehrern und einreisenden
insbesondere eben wenn sie aus dem
urlaub zurückkommen um infektionsketten
dann in deutschland und entdeckte zu
vermeiden
und wir wollen dabei die richtige
balance finden was die test verordnung
angeht zwischen flächendeckende
infrastruktur an jeder ecke in stadt und
land leicht verfügbar und gleichzeitig
eben den betrug den wir gesehen haben
auch mit krimineller energie so weit es
geht unterbinden wir sind gerade in den
finalen abstimmung der neuen test
verordnung mit den ländern den kassen
ersten allen beteiligten und ich gehe
davon aus die nächste woche
unterzeichnen zu können
abschließend impfen vorsicht testen
damit kann es gelingen die
infektionszahlen weiter runter zu
bringen und auch unten zu halten über
den ganzen sommer
die frage wird im übrigen nicht sein ob
delta die dominante variante auch in
deutschland und in kontinentaleuropa
wird sondern eher die frage wann und
unter welchen bedingungen idealerweise
unter bedingungen mit hoher impfquote
und geringen infektionszahlen und das
kann dann eben einmal mehr in der
paarung von zuversicht und vorsicht dann
der ausblick für die
wochen sein herzlichen dank bis hierhin
und wir machen weiter bei wird morgen
meine damen und herren wir sind
tatsächlich sehr froh und sehr dankbar
darüber wie sich die zahlen entwickeln
aber die pandemie ist eben nicht vorbei
weder in deutschland noch weltweit
das virus ist nicht verschwunden und es
wird auch nicht mehr verschwinden lassen
sie uns die erfolge nicht leichtfertig
verspielen lassen sie uns die auch
wieder gewonnene freiheit erhalten in
dem sich immer mehr menschen vollständig
impfen lassen indem wir die basis
infektionsschutz maßnahmen inklusive das
tragen von mund nasenschutz beibehalten
auch bei niedrigen fallzahlen und indem
wir weiterhin auch wirklich nur behutsam
und kleinen schritten öffnen wenn wir
die maßnahmen zu für lockern dann kann
sich das virus wieder sehr schnell
verbreiten
vor allem in den bevölkerungsgruppen in
denen eben noch nicht so viele geimpft
sind
das dürfen wir einfach nicht riskieren
das robert koch institut steht ja auch
im austausch mit vielen internationalen
partnern und natürlich auch mit
kolleginnen und kollegen in
großbritannien dort waren die fallzahlen
seit märz vergleichsweise niedrig im mai
wurde dann recht weitgehend geöffnet
zu diesem zeitpunkt waren etwa 30
prozent der menschen vollständig geimpft
in großbritannien seit anfang juni
steigen die fallzahlen aber in
großbritannien wieder stark an nach den
daten der britischen kollegen liegt die
sieben tage incident jetzt wieder bei 70
am häufigsten sind übrigens dabei
menschen unter 50 betroffen es müssen
auch wieder mehr menschen mit 19
krankenhaus behandelt werden
und die meisten neuinfektionen in
großbritannien tatsächlich mehr als 90
prozent gehen inzwischen auf die welter
variante zurück erhält er das ist die
variante die wir zunächst in indien
entdeckt hatten und die britischen
kollegen gehen davon aus dass sie noch
ansteckender ist als bei 117 das ist die
variante die wir als alpha bezeichnen
also wesentlich ansteckender als die
viren die noch im letzten jahr in
deutschland
gags waren und impft daten aus
großbritannien zeigen zwar dass die
impfung von biontech und astrazeneca
sehr gut vor schweren verläufen durch
delta schützen
das gilt aber eben nur für vollständig
kämpfte bei einer unvollständigen im
stereo kann die delta variante weiter
übertragen werden und wegen der starken
ausbeute die ältere variante hat
großbritannien das hat über letzter
sparen bereits gesagt die eröffnungs
schritte weitere öffnung schritte um
vier wochen verschoben so was bedeutet
das nun mit blick auf unser land auf
deutschland auch hier spielt die delta
variante eine rolle aber im moment noch
keine grosse hier zirkuliert weiter
hauptsächlich die alpha variante die
welte variante hat im moment einen
anteil von rund 6 prozent
das können sie auch dem gestrigen
bericht nehmen aber der anteil nimmt zu
wir müssen diese entwicklung daher sehr
genau beobachten es ist nämlich klar
dass die entwicklung eben davon abhängt
wie wir die maßnahmen weiterhin umsetzen
es ist tatsächlich keine frage ob die
eltern die führende wird sondern nur
wann
und es hängt auch sehr stark von den im
quoten ab und es hängt davon ab wie wir
mit lockerungen umgehen im moment haben
wir in deutschland einen 7 tagen sind
sie denn von 10 und etwas mehr als 50
prozent der menschen nicht einmal
geimpft und fast neun oder mehr als 29
prozent sind zweimal geimpft vollständig
gibt das heißt aber bei dieser ganzen
guten entwicklung trotzdem ist fast die
hälfte der menschen eben immer noch
nicht vollständig geschützt und was man
auch mit bedenken muss das ist ein teil
der geimpften trotzdem infizieren und
das virus weiter geben kann der
impfschutz kann bei varianten zum
beispiel bei delta auch geringer
ausfallen und auch bei vollständig
geimpften kommen dann noch in seltenen
fällen einzelne schwere
krankheitsverläufe vor
deshalb bleiben die anderen maßnahmen
das wird dich immer zu beachten
trotz der niedrigen fallzahlen nach wie
vor sehr wichtig abstand halten
hygiene einhalten in bestimmten
situationen mund nasenschutz tagen und
lüften also die wirklich gut bekannten
art + 11
und auch die kontakt tradition und dass
man bei symptomen zu hause bleibt
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung testen
ist wichtig und quarantänemaßnahmen und
ich möchte das noch betonen das gilt
eben auch dort wo die inzidenz niedrig
sind wir dürfen dem virus keine chance
geben sich wieder erneut zu verbreiten
daher empfiehlt das robert koch-institut
diese basismaßnahmen mindestens so lange
bei zu halten
bis alle für die ein impfstoff
zugelassen und eine impfung empfohlen
ist die gelegenheit hatten sich
vollständig impfen zu lassen
also erst einmal mindestens bis zum
herbst danach muss man die situation
wieder neu bewerten
und das gilt natürlich auch für das
tragen von mund nasen schutz
das robert-koch-institut empfiehlt auch
in bestimmten situationen weiter und
nasenschutz zu tragen besonders in
innenräumen im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr am arbeitsplatz und
situationsbedingt natürlich auch in
schulen
je mehr menschen in solchen situationen
eine maske tragen desto besser sind alle
geschützt dann wird der solidarische
fremdschutz auch zu einem eigenschutz
und im freien kann man in der regel auf
massen verzichten wenn ein abstand von
einem meter fünfzig sicher eingehalten
werden kann
wir haben eine neue faq dazu
veröffentlicht die finden sie auf
unserer website www.rtl.de lassen sie
uns die erfolge die wir gemeinsam
erzielt haben jetzt auch bitte
gemeinsamen sichern
lassen sie uns die freiheit und die
sicherheit die wir uns in den letzten
monaten wirklich hart erarbeitet haben
weiter verteidigen
wir können wieder in wachsendem maße
freiheiten genießen diese freiheiten
müssen wir bei jedem tag schützen
alles was wir an maßnahmen jetzt weiter
berücksichtigen bei gleichzeitig hoher
impfbereitschaft das hilft uns für den
kommenden herbst wenn erfahrungsgemäß
die zahlen steigen
bis dahin werden nicht alle
bevölkerungsgruppen geimpft sein
diese schützen wir indem wir den sommer
nutzen und die zahlen möglichst drücke
bitte beherzigen sie weiter deshalb die
basismaßnahmen bitte lassen sie sich
impfen wenn sie die gelegenheit zu
bekommen
bitte nehmen sie auch vor allem die
zweite impfung
nur mit einer vollständigen impfung sind
sie bestmöglich geschützt
so kommen wir sicher durch den sommer
und meistern auch den herbst
wir haben wirklich schöne erfolge
erzielt aber das virus ist immer noch
aktiv geben wir diesen virus bitte keine
chance danke auch ihn hernieder und dann
kommen last but not least guten morgen
meine damen und herren
mein name ist ralf franke ich bin der
leitender betriebsarzt siemens ag und
zusammen mit meinen kolleginnen kollegen
des betriebsärztlichen dienstes
betreuende circa 90.000 mitarbeiter der
siemens ag
aber auch einige mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter von siemens energy und
siemens 10 erst wir freuen uns ganz
besonders dass wir jetzt die gelegenheit
haben mit unserem betriebsärztlichen
betriebsärzten zur brandbekämpfung in
deutschland einen beitrag zu leisten
aber noch mehr freuen sich unsere
mitarbeitenden dass sie jetzt ein
angebot zur impfung von uns bekommen wir
bereit und seit april auf die
impfkampagne vor
wir haben also 60 betriebe im straßen
eingerichtet
an größeren standorten werkhallen
umfunktioniert konferenzzentren
umfunktioniert oder auch zelte gebaut an
kleineren standorten büros
umfunktioniert und sind jetzt holt
klasse ist jetzt losgeht
wir haben im mai schon mal trainieren
könnte ein bisschen üben können wir
haben also an pilotprojekten von
landesregierung sich zum beispiel hier
in berlin oder auch in bayern
teilgenommen
unser zum beispiel unser standort ihn
kam an der tschechischen grenze war
damals hoch incidents gebiet und wurde
dann an das lokale impfzentrum
angeschlossen das war eine wunderbare
zusammenarbeit
wir haben den impfstoff im impfzentrum
bestellt das impfzentrum hat geliefert
wir haben gekämpft und das im zentrum
hat uns bei der dokumentation
unterstützt
wunderbar interessant war die erkenntnis
dass nur die hälfte unserer mitarbeiter
zum impfen kam warum weil eben in dieser
region schon viele der mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter geimpft waren was ja gut
ist so jetzt ist letzte woche der
startschuss für die bundesweite kampagne
gefallen und wir haben eineinhalb wochen
vorher den impfstoff bestellt und da
muss man wissen dass der impfstoff pro
betriebsarzt zugeteilt wird
also das heißt wir haben für die letzte
woche 102 impfstoffe piontek zugeteilt
bekommen diese woche waren es 84 und
nächste woche wenn es voraussichtlich
108 impfdosen pro betriebsarzt sein
wir haben auch letzten montag also
mutter vor acht tagen unser
anmeldesystem freigeschalten und sie
kann es kaum glauben
der andrang war riesig und innerhalb von
einigen minuten war das system
ausgebucht waren keine termine mehr frei
was natürlich eindeutig zeigt dass die
bereitschaft und zum impfen zu gehen
sehr hoch ist und einige mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter waren
schlichtweg auch frustriert weil sie
keinen termin bekommen haben aber das
ist ja jetzt auch nichts neues das
kennen wir von den impfzentren von den
hausärzten damit wir uns ein bisschen in
geduld üben was aber glaube ich uns
allen gut tut
ich selber habe letzte woche auch beim
impfen mitgeholfen und das war für mich
ein überwältigendes erlebnis zu sehen
wie schnell man menschen glücklich
machen kann sich so eine einfache
maßnahme wie impfen ja in glückliche
gesichter reinzuschauen e mails zu
bekommen social media feedback zu
bekommen weil die mitarbeiter dankbar
sind dass das unternehmen ihnen so ein
angebot macht ein beispiel ist auch dass
wir in der produktion mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter haben die jetzt nicht
unbedingt online sich anmelden können
und da ist es dann so dass der meist
darum geht und fragt also wer sich
impfen lassen und dann heben wir die
hand von der welt eine liste gemacht und
gibt sie dann ins termin system ein und
allein durch diese gruppendynamik werden
ganz viele mitarbeiter überzeugt die
sich vielleicht vor
nicht impfen lassen wollen doch
mitzugehen
das heißt also wir haben da die
möglichkeit weil wir einerseits nah am
menschen sind am mitarbeitenden weil die
mitarbeitenden vertrauen zu uns
betriebsärzte haben weil sie uns kennen
aber auch weil die gruppe schlichtweg
zum impfen geht mehr menschen zu
erreichen als sonst womöglich also
insgesamt wir haben uns jetzt warm
gelaufen und freuen uns auf mehr
impfstoff damit man in zukunft noch mehr
menschen glücklich machen können
vielen dank könnte der eindruck
entstanden sein ganz siemens hätte nur
102 dosen bekommen da sie ja deswegen
werde vielleicht muss ich noch mal die
gesamt 1000 also wir haben insgesamt
sechs aus und impfstoffe letzte woche
bekommen ich weiß nicht immer noch nicht
aber ist jedenfalls mehr als 102 vielen
dank dass hier hin ich beginne an dieser
stelle mit einer frage digital weil sich
die unmittelbar an das gesagte
anschließt herr buchsteiner von der
pioneer fragt zur ausbreitung der delta
barney an doch sie sagt es wurde ja
schon gesagt
die frage ist nicht bis wann sie sich in
deutschland durchsetzt
ob sie sich in deutschland durch sondern
es warm und die frage ist eben kann sie
da einen zeitpunkt in diesem sommer
nennen an dem die del der variante 80
oder 90 prozent der infektionen ausmacht
und müsste dann nicht auch relativ rasch
mit auffrischungsimpfungen begonnen
werden richtet sich an dass ihr sparen
also zu der frage einer einer
einschätzung würde ich gleich ein
professor wähler auch noch mal bitten
was wir jetzt noch mal vereinbart haben
mit den laboren und dem robert koch
institut ist dass wir das gleiche machen
was wir bei beginn der japaner wieder
britischen gesagt der variante alpha
gemacht haben nämlich alle positiv
testung genom sequenzieren also nicht
nur stichprobenartig nicht nur die die
im verdacht haben wir gewisse tätigkeit
oder anderen sondern alle so wie wir das
alle zwei wochen auch im januar februar
gemacht haben mit blick auf variante
alpha um auch für diese variante einen
noch besseren überblick über das
geschehen in deutschland zu haben das
ist schon mal sehr wichtig habe schon
mal hier gesagt wir sind übrigens wir
waren im dezember mittel
beim genom sequenzieren und wir sind
mittlerweile bei den top fünf weltweit
auch in dieser frage und das klappt sehr
gut
aktuell einfach nur zur einordnung wenn
wir natürlich zu sagen wir mal 1000 neue
infektionen am tag haben wie in etwa
heute dann heißt 6% 60 das ist stand
jetzt eine relativ kleine zahl der
entscheidende teil ist ja dass diese 60
noch mehr alle darauf achten dass diese
infektionskette unterbrochen werden dass
wir es also schaffen dass gerade die
weiterverbreitung es gilt für jede
infektion aber gerade bei dieser
variante wirklich jeder kontakt
nachverfolgt wird quarantäne eingehalten
und kontrolliert wird und gerade weil 60
eigentlich eine relativ kleine zahl auf
eine gesamte bundesrepublik ist ist
jetzt zumindest die chance da es
möglichst lange hinauszuzögern wenn es
uns gelingt immer schnell zu
identifizieren und infektionskette zu
unterbrechen ob man sagen kann wie lange
das ist eine modellierungs frage würde
ich sagen ja
also zunächst ist es noch mal wirklich
wichtig zu verstehen also diese delta
variante wird die überhand nehmen wenn
sie anhören erwert hat also das ist
biologisch logisch das wird geschehen
die frage wann das geschehen wird hängt
wirklich davon ab wie wir das managen
das heißt also es hängt wirklich davon
ab inwieweit wert dieser variante die
chance geben überhaupt infektionen
hervorrufen und das ist etwas was wir
auch seid wirklich vielen monaten sagen
alle die maßnahmen die wir haben
dieser werkzeugkasten alle diese
maßnahmen die unterdrücken ja auch die
infektion mit diesem virus mit dieser
variante hält mehr gegen alle masken
helfen gegen alle und die verschiedenen
möglichkeiten die wir haben helfen gegen
alle varianten
das heißt die beantwortung wann diese
variante die hoheit über nimmt liegt
sehr stark davon hängt davon ab wie wir
uns in der zukunft verhalten
sie wird spätestens im herbst natürlich
die überhand nehmen spätestens im herbst
weil im herbst die zahlen ansteigen
werden es gibt einen gewissen saisonalen
und dann wird es wieder zu mehr
ansteckung kommen darum ist es so wie
ich dass wir jetzt die ansteckung zu
unterhalten
und dass dann insgesamt unabhängig davon
wie groß der anteil der variante ist
einfach wenig felle davon
es geht doch immer darum dass wir
möglichst wenig menschen infiziert haben
möchten möglichst wenig kranke auch
todesfälle
die delta variante sie haben das auch
gehört die kommt ja auch häufiger bei
jüngeren menschen vor das liegt unter
anderem auch daran dass eben die älteren
menschen auch geimpft sind und besser
geschützt sind das heißt also wir werden
den jetzt auch wieder jüngere fälle in
großbritannien zum beispiel das heißt
der ganze aspekt egal wann diese
variante auch nach welchen modellierung
wie hoch sein wird wir müssen die zahlen
unten halten das ist glaube ich das ganz
entscheidende und dazu helfen die
basismaßnahmen und dazu hilft die
impfbereitschaft in hohem maße und ich
möchte auch noch sagen dass eben die
daten die wir bislang haben die zeigen
uns dass mit den impfstoffen astrazeneca
also in zugelassenen stoffen in
deutschland in immunschutz immer noch
hoch ist
ja das ist auch sehr wichtig zu sagen
wir haben ein anderes land wenn man nach
chile gucken da haben wir auch eine sehr
hohe wenn du durch impfung aber mit
einem impfstoff der nicht so eine hohe
effektivität hat und dort breitet sich
diese gelte variante sehr stark aus dort
haben sie auch viele todesfälle unter
jungen menschen
das heißt also das fazit ist wir müssen
alles dafür tun die zahlen kunden zu
halten und das ist das aller
wesentlichen dazu haben wir alle
maßnahme selber sagt vielen dank dann
bin ich beim kollegen in der mitte herr
reichert eine frage zu den massen herr
sprachen sie wieder seit wochen auf
kritik an ihrem system der ausbruch von
krones sei eine singuläre situation
gewesen habe die man schnell reagieren
müssen und stellt ihnen der
bundesrechnungshof ein vernichtendes
zeugnis der masten beschaffung aus dass
die rede von massiver über beschaffung
mangelhafter aktenführung es ist nicht
deine zeit dass sie hier und heute auch
an erklären welche fehler aus ihrer
sicht gemacht wurden und wie sie die in
ihrem ministerium abstellen
denner sag ich was dazu zuerst einmal
erinnere ich aber noch mal dran und das
sagt im übrigen ja auch der
bundesrechnungshof in seinem bericht
welcher ausnahmesituationen das gewesen
ist im letzten jahr im frühjahr mit
kliniken die gesagt haben sie müssten
den betrieb einstellen wenn sie nicht
sehr bald zusätzliche schutzmasken
bekommen wo wir eine zeit lang auch
verfahren ja entwickelt habe eine
zeitlang das wirklich gemacht worden ist
dass diese masken diese jetzt so schnell
verfügbaren masken tatsächlich wieder
benutzt worden sind wieder verwendet
worden sind nach einer entsprechenden
dekontamination ich erinnere noch das
desinfektionsmittel und schutzmasken
geklaut worden sind aber so wenn man
noch erinnern was das für eine zeit
leider sind diese masken die heute
überall verfügbar sind geklaut worden
weil es mangelware war weltweit und das
finde ich wichtig für die einordnung und
ja ich bin der meinung besser 1000 zu
viel als einmal zu wenig das gilt für
beatmungsgeräte das gilt für
schutzmasken das gilt übrigens auch für
impfstoffe ich bin sehr sicher wenn sie
den gleichen massstab anlegen der jetzt
angelegt wird wird man in einem jahr
sagen wir haben zuviel impfstoffe zu
teuer bestellt wir werden welche über
haben also klar wenn man sozusagen die
maßstäbe einer normalen situation anlegt
dann ist das was wir in dieser notlage
in dieser besonderen machen
unkonventionell das ist so es ist aber
auch die größte krise seit bestehen der
bundesrepublik
und ich bin sehr sehr sicher zu wenig
schutzmasken zu wenig bergungsgerät zu
wenig impfstoff
das würde uns deutlich teurer gekommen
sein
man muss ja auch mal die gegenfrage
stellen was wäre denn gewesen wenn es zu
wenig gewesen wäre
und manchmal habe ich so den eindruck
die diskus in der diskussion auch im
rückblick ich finde wir haben ein großes
bild nehme ein großbrand gelöscht
erfolgreich gelöscht jetzt auch mehrere
wellen mehrere brände
und anschließend ist die diskussion die
man führen muss
das grüne wegfuhren aber die frage ob es
zu viel wasser war oder löschwasser
daneben lief das finde ich halt wichtig
einzuordnen wenn sie aber fragen
richtigerweise was ist die lehre daraus
die lehre ist dass wir auch für
pandemien mehr vorbereitung brauchen und
mehr sicherheitsinstitutionen brauchen
wir haben für einen katastrophenfall
haben wir institutionen haben wir
operative einheiten haben wir pläne die
wir üben für den verteidigungsfall haben
wir die ganze bundeswehr haben wir pläne
üben wir für den pandemiefall hatten wir
zwar pläne aber wir haben sie nie geübt
und werden in wahrheit weder die
vorhaltung noch die struktur gehabt und
damit vernünftig umzugehen und die
institutionen dies gab der
bundesrechnungshof sagt ja sind nicht
die klassischen institutionen und die
wege ja wir haben's ja versucht über
beschaffungs ämter es ist ja nicht so
als wenn wir es nicht versucht hätten
auf dem weg auf den man sonst geschafft
nämlich die beschaffungs ämter zu bitten
für uns masken zu kaufen wenn ich halt
eine woche für woche erlebe dass die
dort beschafften masten nicht ankommen
gar nichts es kam halt nix auf diesem
weg dann habe ich ja zwei alternativen
ich kann sagen ist halt so sagt den
pflegekräften tut mir leid oder ja ich
tue alles damit wir schutzmasken für
pflegekräfte ärzte und damit auch für
patienten und die versorgung in
deutschland bekommen wir haben uns für
letzteres entschieden und damit war das
nicht noch mal so machen müssen braucht
es eben die nationale reserve
gesundheitsschutz in der wir seit einem
jahr
konzeptionell arbeiten mit dem
innenministerium mit dem
verteidigungsministerium das jetzt zug
um zug umsetzen muss darum geht zu
definieren welche schutzgüter
verbrauchsgüter medizinisch wir
bevorraten wollen für die zukunft
das kostet übrigens geld dann bevorraten
aber lücken stopfen ist immer teurer als
bevorraten haben wir gelernt wir haben
vorgestern entschieden in der
bundesregierung dass wir jetzt pandemie
bereitschafts verträge ausschreiben
werden für impfstoffproduktion auch das
eine lehre des impfstoffs
produktionskapazitäten
wir immer für fünf jahre am markt
ausschreiben einkaufen 600 bis 700
millionen dosen kapazität im jahr
dafür zahlen wir eine gebühr aber im
fall der fälle können wir dann sofort
auch zu greifen auf diese
produktionskapazität auch eine lehre aus
der knappheit und der not das jetzt auch
in vorsorge zu machen und es braucht
operative strukturen
das bundesministerium für gesundheit und
da hat der bundesrechnungshof hat völlig
recht ist kein klassisches beschaffungs
ministerium das sind wir nicht
deswegen ist eben die frage wird auch
nicht per sehen operatives ministerium
wir haben keine bundespolizei wir haben
kein zoll
wir sind nicht diejenigen die die
gesundheitsämter die kommunalen
irgendwie dirigieren können und wollen
wir auch gar nicht im verein miteinander
aber wir brauchen offensichtlich
operative strukturen im ministerium
haben wir da schon eine abteilung neu
gegründet gesundheitssicherheit ganz neu
gegründet um das zu adressieren wir
reden darüber wie das zusammenspiel auch
ist von robert koch-institut bundesamt
für bevölkerungsschutz wie wir
institutionell die dinge besser
vernetzen können ob wir auch die
behörden ein struktur weiter entwickeln
müssen um einfach im fall der fälle beim
nächsten mal tatsächlich und dafür ist
der bundesrechnungshof bericht ja gut
und hilfreich besser vorbereitet sein zu
können aber ich kann halt gleichzeitig
nur dafür werben sich gelegentlich daran
zu erinnern was für eine notsituation
das alles gewesen ist und dass die
maßstäbe jedenfalls des behördlichen
alltags nicht ganz zur jahrhundertkrise
immer passen
eine nachfrage ersparen wenn sie sagen
lieber eine zu viel liebe 1000 so viel
dass eine zu wenig der
bundesrechnungshof sagt sie hätten
ungefähr zehn mal zu viel gekauft wenn
man davon ausgeht dass er den
mindestbedarf ermittlung von knapp von
der million masken da war sie rund 500
milliarden gekauft haben jetzt über eine
milliarde in der reserve wandern soll
kann es sein dass sie im märz deshalb so
weht eingekauft haben weil sie zuvor
ebenso wie herr weder den nutzen von
geleugnet haben wird einfach nicht früh
genug angekauft haben also zuerst einmal
geht es hier nicht um leugnung sondern
ich weiß noch wie wir hier saßen beiden
seiten bundespressekonferenz und wenig
karin und hygieniker mit mir hier saßen
klinische hygieniker professoren aus
kliniken die sich mit hygiene
beschäftigen und hier gesagt haben aus
ihrer damaligen überhaupt niemandem
vorwurf ich will die nummer sagen das
ging nicht um leugnen
ich finde den begriff ehrlich gesagt
etwas fehl am platze in wenn man schaut
und welche debatte ist geht sondern es
beantworte nur fragen haben
hygieniker gesagt aus dem klinischen
alltag das tatsächlich mit dem damaligen
erkenntnisstand damalige erkenntnisstand
schutzmasken für den medizinischen
betrieb sinn machen für kliniken und in
den praxen aber darüber hinaus nicht das
war damals die aussage
und dann hat sich der erkenntnisstand
weiterentwickelt und der professor
wähler hat ja auch mehrfach schon darauf
hingewiesen dass hat er auch beim
robert-koch-institut und bei anderen
institutionen das ist wissenschaft es
hat nichts mit leugnen oder wahrheit
oder unwahrheit zu tun das ist
wissenschaft und für uns in der politik
war eben ist gleichzeitig maß schnur
auch wissenschaftliche erkenntnis zur
grundlage unserer entscheidung zu machen
und auch entsprechend zu handeln
das hat aber nichts mit der frage zu tun
ob und in welchem umfang für masten
beschaffen für die frage des bedarfs den
wir haben da ich selber mehrfach ancona
kabinettssitzung teilgenommen habe wohl
nicht nur ich sondern auch das
wirtschaftsministerium beispielsweise
für die frage wie viele produktionen
reizen wir eigentlich an wenn sie sich
mal anschauen welchen bedarf das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit unserer
unterstützung wir gemeinsam definiert
haben wie viele inländische produktion
brauchen wir eigentlich um autark zu
sein von chinesischer produktion dann
ist das alles in milliarden größte
stückzahl größenordnung ist ja auch ich
meinen wir am 5 millionen beschäftigte
im gesundheitswesen
eigentlich sollen sie diese maske
zumindest mal im medizinischen betrieb
mehr
am tag wechseln ich weiß dass viele sie
mehrere tage nutzen aber für den
medizinischen betrieb mehrfach am tag
wechselt 5 millionen beschäftigte 45
masken am tag 30 tage im jahr sind im
monat sind sie schon relativ schnell in
relativ großen größenordnung und diese
zahlen haben wir auch hergeleitet die
habe ich auch in corona kabinett
vorgetragen und die hat im übrigen haben
auch andere ressorts mit uns hergeleitet
und vorgetragen und ein drittes dazu das
ist wie mit den impfstoffen
wir wussten ja nicht im vorhinein
welcher beschaffungs weg zu welchem
erfolg führen ich weiß noch sehr genau
ich kann mich noch sehr genau an die
minute erinnern als wir uns für dieses
sogenannte open house verfahren
entschieden haben das jetzt so viele
diskussionen auslöst übrigens open house
verfahren sind unter zehn prozent der
masten gekommen am ende aber 99 prozent
des ärgers aber das wussten wir damals
nicht und ich weiß noch sehr genau als
wir das entschieden haben haben wir
überlegt wird überhaupt ein angebot
eingehen
angesichts des marktpreises der damals
da war und dann hat china seine
exportpolitik innerhalb von zwei wochen
zwei mal verändert und dafür einmal bei
der marktpreis ein völlig anderer
das wussten wir aber in dem moment der
entscheidung nicht dann können sie sagen
hätten sie doch ihre erscheinung
vielleicht noch vier wochen aufschieben
können wir wissen was in china passiert
denn hätte ich aber in der folgewoche
ganz andere diskussion gehabt im
gesundheitswesen und deswegen jahr haben
wir auf mehr als einen beschaffungswege
gesetzt genauso wie wir jetzt auf mehr
als einen impfstoff setzen hätten wir
stellen immer vorwände auf astra zenica
gesetzt oder nur auf einen der beiden
deutschen hersteller gesetzt in welcher
situation wir jetzt seien würden aus
meiner sicht war es richtig in dieser
pandemie
in dieser notlage auf unterschiedliche
wege zu setzen weil das nicht verfügbar
sein von masken beatmungsgeräten und
impfstoffen aus unserer aus meiner
einschätzung am ende immer teurer ist
als möglicherweise zu viel zu sagen
möchte gern noch mal den aspekt der
masken wirkung erläutert und den
kenntnisstand es gibt zwei wesentliche
erkenntnisse
die zu beginn dieser pandemie nicht
vorhanden worden die also nicht im
wissenschaftlichen umfeld akzeptiert und
bekannt waren das erste ein ganz großer
teil der infizierten scheidet schon sehr
große virusmengen aus wovor er
symptomatisch erkannt wir nennen das
eine präsente virus ausschalten das sind
rund 50 prozent der gesamten videos lass
das ist ein für die für die bekämpfung
der pandemie ein unglaublicher eine
unglaubliche herausforderung weil die
menschen gesund sind gar nicht wissen
dass sie schon virus aus scheint diese
präsent thematische ausscheidung war zu
beginn dieser pandemie schlichtweg nicht
bekannt wir kannten dieses phänomen
nicht
ich hatte es mehrfach erklärt dass das
das kauf 1 virus und das saas kopf 2
virus genetisch natürlich hoch verwandt
sind aber bestimmte unterschiede haben
die dazu führen dass dieses kaff 2 virus
ist sehr viel stärker im oberen mund
nasen rachenraum vermehrt das ist das
eine
der zweite aspekt der nicht bekannt war
in dem maße war die ausbreitung barroso
lhe tröpfcheninfektion standen lange
zeit im fokus und tröpfcheninfektionen
haben natürlich eine ganz andere
ballistik die ausbreitung und räumen ist
ganz anders und das heißt diese
ausbreitung über aro sohle ist ebenfalls
ein aspekt warum masken in der höhere
wirksamkeit haben als das zu beginn der
pandemie gedacht wurden lassen die
beiden aspekte warum die die die wirkung
der masken zu beginn unterschätzt holen
das ist das ist so und das sollte man
auch immer zur kenntnis haben heutzutage
wissen wir dass alle und heutzutage
propagieren wir deshalb diese dinge das
ist eben erkenntnis zu gewinnen und ich
bin sehr glücklich dass wir diesen
erkenntnisgewinn haben weil wir sonst
diese pandemie nicht in dem haus hätten
bekämpfen können noch zwei kurze
hinweise digital bitte jede frage nur
ein x eintragen und auch digital die
regel nur eine frage und eine nachfrage
ich kann jetzt schon ankündigen dass
alle fragen vermutlich nicht das ist für
alle vertragen nicht zeit finden werden
deswegen auch die bitte halten sie sich
die rege bitte um knappe fragen knapp
beantworten und ich bin bei herrn
goldschmieds von deutsche welle
lateinamerika zu dem impfpass für eu
ausländer die im bescheinigungen von
reisenden aus nicht eu staaten werden
nur anerkannt wenn der impfstoff thema
zugelassen wurde die zulassung stellt
sicher dass der impfstoff wirksam und
sicher ist der kollege sagt mir nur bei
ausländischen touristen ist lediglich
die frage relevant ob diese menschen das
virus übertragen oder nicht ist
diesbezüglich ein schneller das
verfahren zur anerkennung nicht
zugelassene impfstoffe möglich also das
ist ein thema das uns am dienstag auch
im gesundheitsminister der eu in
luxemburg beschäftigt hat ich habe wie
einige andere kollegen auch sehr stark
dafür geworben dass aus unserer sicht
aus deutscher sicht sehr wünschenswert
wäre muss ich leider sagen wenn wir ein
einheitliches vorgehen der europäischen
union hätten bei man erkennen von also
in der frage welche anderen impfstoffe
erkennen wir als sozusagen
gleichgestellt an für die frage von
reisen und mobilität gehen wir alle
davon aus dass man den vollen impfschutz
haben sollte also beide impfungen da wo
zwei impfungen den vollen impfschutz
bringen oder reicht schon eine wie
einige länder das handhaben für
bestimmte dinge wann ist eine nach
impfung erforderlich damit der digitale
oder der überhaupt was seine gültigkeit
fürs reisen behält leider muss ich sagen
stand jetzt haben wir dazu noch keine
einheitliche vorgehensweise weil
einzelne mitgliedstaaten aus
unterschiedlichen gründen das noch nicht
mittragen
und das ist ein problem für einen raum
des freien reisens wie es die
europäische union ist wir haben eins
geschafft den digitalen eu impfpass das
ist eine errungenschaft die hat noch
keine andere region der welt geschafft
dass mehr als ein staat überhaupt
definiert hat miteinander
die technologische lösung das gibt's
nicht mal in den usa bundeseinheitlich
für die usa
wir haben übrigens wenn ich das noch
erwähnen da stand heute 18,3 millionen
er stellte im zertifikate digital
bereits also viele haben das auch und
können das dann auch
in der hinweisen aber es gibt objektiv
ein problem das noch nicht gelöst ist
dass man sich zu bestehen wie in der
frage deutlich geworden ist und wenn wir
es nicht schaffen ist jetzt zeit nach eu
ebene zu lösen werden wir für
deutschland eigene definition vornehmen
müssen welche impfstoffe wir als
gleichwertig oder gleich gleich fertig
sag ich jetzt mal anerkennen
es geht ja fahren um die frage ob der
wert mit viele vor allem auch um die
frage nicht nur was schützt vor kobelt
das ist ja bei allen vero zulassung der
hauptfokus das geht eben auch um die
frage wie sehr werden infektionen
eigentlich auch eher reduziert digitalen
im passauer kollegen vom handelsblatt
einige apotheken und ärzte haben die
zertifikate für den digitalen
impfnachweis ohne identifikations
prüfung vor ort durchgeführt was nicht
erlaubt sein dürfte es gibt keine
nachträgliche sperrfunktion für den
digitalen im nachweisen wollen sie
darauf reagieren also zuerst einmal und
dafür ist ja nun wirklich eine
angemessene vergütung vorgesehen ist die
klare regel und die vorgabe ein
identitätsnachweis bei der eintragung
des digitalen impfpass aber übrigens
nicht nur bei der eintragung sondern
auch bei der kontrolle und ich finde da
müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen weil
ich heute auch eine öffentliche debatte
gesehen habe in der analogen welt könnte
ich ja auch theoretisch den impfpass
meiner mutter nehmen und wenn keiner
guckt ob ich wirklich ob das wirklich
meiner ist sondern einfach nur guckt
sind die beiden impfungen drin aber
nicht guckt was ist das eigentlich
dann kommt man weit das stimmt deswegen
muss man sowohl beim papier impfpass wie
beim digitalen impfpass dass die klare
anforderungen natürlich einmal checken
ob die identität und das wenn man mit
beiden apps das checkt werden wir die
kopatschek app auch kann jeder sich
runterladen sieht man den namen und das
geburtsdatum das im zertifikate inhabers
und wenn da steht bernhard maier und der
personalausweis des anderen ist aber max
mustermann dann ist das offensichtlich
nicht sein digitaler impfpass und diese
kontrolle muss analog wie digital
stattfinden das lässt sich nicht
nicht vermeiden weil es heute auch eine
debatte gab darüber dass man doch bei
den gedruckten im pass den namen
irgendwie auf den gedruckten ändern
könnte das stimmt aber der entscheidende
teil ist sie sollen den qr codes kennen
also ich wundere mich manchmal wie
analog wieder debatten führen sie tragen
ja das klar analog papier mit dem qr
code wenn sie es nicht auf ihrem handy
übertragen weil der andere der testen
der soll ja nicht gucken stimmt der name
sondern er soll mit dem qr code leser
den qr-code lesen und dann abgleichen
daher kommt dann die sicherheit an der
stelle
und deswegen bin ich sehr für
größtmögliche sicherheit
aber wir müssen auch mal den vergleich
zu analogen welt ziehen um zu sehen
welcher mehrwert da ist und es ist
absolut notwendig dass beim übertragen
ins digitale und erstellen des projektes
eine identitätsprüfung stattfindet also
wenn das der vorfälle gibt dann zweifel
auch uns melden dann muss dir
nachgegangen werden das ist rechtswidrig
und im zweifel auch nicht die
sorgfaltspflicht die man von einem
halben der frage wenn ich schon mal da
bin und will mich doch mal indizien dass
die nachricht vom gestrigen tag des
impfstoffs und jurek wahrgenommen wurde
wie viel das jetzt ausmacht in der
impfstrategie und ja wie man damit
eigentlich umgeht das war ja auch ein
bisschen der impfstoff eigentlich für
den ärmeren teil der welt also zuerst
einmal was die wirksamkeitsdaten die
studiendaten frankenberg angeht finde
ich es richtig dass tür weg sich dazu
verhält und das ein öffnet das muss vom
unternehmen her auch gemacht werden
die bewertung der entsprechenden daten
wenn sie eingereicht werden wird dann
die zulassungsbehörde machen für uns
jetzt für die frage was bedeutet das für
die impfkampagne ist vermindert das
tempo unserer impfkampagne nicht sondern
das was ich gerade gesagt habe die
beiden immer in einem stoffe von
moderner und bayon tag alleine würden es
uns stand heute möglich machen bis ende
juli
die erwachsenen empfehlen mindestens
einmal zu impfen
es kommt der impfstoff von astra
zinecker und johnson johnson noch dazu
sozusagen als sicherheitspuffer in der
kalkulation erwarten von astra zenica
doch auch in diesem quartal sogar
relativ große lieferung weil sich sagen
sie wurden für dieses quartal in die vom
einhalten
insofern zur einordnung der studienlage
würde ich an das unternehmen selbst
verweisen wollen für die frage was macht
das mit der impfkampagne kann ich nur
sagen ist verlangsamt sich also der weg
ist ja das ist übrigens der grund warum
wir ich komme daher darauf nochmal
zurück warum wir auf mehrere pferde
gesetzt haben ich habe ja auch manchmal
schon gedacht was machst du eigentlich
was macht der bundesrechnungshof
möglicherweise wenn alle impfstoffe ins
ziel kommen und alle geliefert werden
weil wir alle bestellt haben also wir
haben deutlich über bestellt bei 56
herstellern und wir werden das übrigens
für 2022 und 23 genauso machen
wir werden und da werde ich auch in der
eu für nicht nur auf bayern tech pfizer
setzen auch wenn das rollo mega vertrag
ist braucht aus meiner sicht mehrere
pferde und das gilt auch für die
internationale impfstoff kampagne jveg
leistet dazu würde könnte wird leisten
einen wichtigen beitrag aber kein
alleinigen was man ja den satz war ich
dann doch schon auch zugestehen muss und
sehen muss für weg hat natürlich in
seinen studien jetzt auch schon die
varianten ganz anders mit einbezogen für
seine erst studien einbeziehen können
wegen des zeitverzugs dann an der stelle
und deswegen also jeder impfstoff gelb
jetzt vielleicht in der ersten runde
noch nicht dabei ist ein auf die hatte
ja eine ähnliche situation ist weiter
dran geblieben er hat ja das potenzial
dann auch für das thema von varianten
und booster impfungen auch dabei zu sein
wobei frauen ich bin ich mir sicher dass
es gewählt hat und an der pflege rechts
hin
vielen dank ich habe eine frage an sie
herr professor wähler sie malina
extremst deutlich das erreichte nicht zu
verspielen
und trotzdem erleben wir jetzt einen
tsunami an lockerungen in den einzelnen
bundesländern die masken fallen außen
klar aber auch in den schulen in ganz
europa öffnet in einigen bundesländern
größere veranstaltungen sind möglich wie
sehr sorgt sie dieses lockerungs
wettrennen und was ist ihre empfehlung
ihre forderung an die politik das ist
dadurch oft münster weiß aus ihrer sicht
in gefahr
ja ich habe denke ich die die empfehlung
des rk ganz klar formuliert wir haben
sehr niedrige incident und die haben wir
deshalb weil wir diese maßnahmen haben
so diese bundes notbremse war sehr
wirksam ein starkes zeichen für die
menschen dass das virus eben unterwegs
ist wir haben die ganzen dieser
werkzeugkasten die jetzt glaube
inzwischen alle kennen wir wir dürfen
das nicht verspielen wir empfehlen ganz
klar weiterhin die nutzung von masken in
innenräumen so wie wir hier ja auch mit
in mit masken sitzen weil wir einfach
die virus verbreitung noch nicht
genügend durch impfungen einnehmen
können das ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen
wir müssen die impfbereitschaft sehr
hoch halten wir gehen davon aus dass
mehr als 80 prozent der deutschen
vollständig geimpft werden müssen das
sind schon sehr viele millionen menschen
und bis das nicht der fall ist sind zu
große locken werden dazu führen dass die
virus ausbreitung wieder zunimmt
und dann hat man natürlich das nächste
netzwerk dass man früh testet das ist
auch sehr wichtig dass testung nicht
eingestellt werden dass man gerade in
schulen zb s concept hat die hygiene
konzepte die auch alle bekannt sind
aber natürlich würden wir gerne dieses
netzwerk gar nicht erst wieder anwerfen
also wir sehen das selbstverständlich
mit sorge wir wünschen dass die
maßnahmen diese basis maßnahmen wirklich
über den winter hinweg auch bleiben dazu
gehört eben das tragen von masken unter
anderem auch in schule von mund nasen
schutz und wir werden dann wenn die
zahlen wieder zunehmen im herbst dann
ist
dass das ist dass sie zu nehmen ist
sicher die infektionszahlen das wird
sich nicht vermeiden dass das ist der
saisonalen effekt und der effekt dass
eben menschen dann auch wieder enger
zusammen kommen mehr menschen in
innenräumen das ist natürlich großartig
zur zeit dass er zu so viel zeit draußen
verbringen können das heißt dann ist die
forderung so viel wie möglich zu impfen
und die inzidenz so niedrig wie möglich
zu halten sonst werden wir halt wieder
lokal bestimmte maßnahmen stärker nehmen
müssen wir haben wir auch den großen
vorteil bei niedrigen zahlen dass die
gesundheitsämter wirklich jetzt viel
besser infekt ketten nachvollziehen
können dann viel schneller infekt ketten
wieder abbrechen können also es gibt nur
gründe die inzidenz tief zu halten und
das müssen wir ständig beobachten und
den maßnahmen entsprechend anpasst
was machen sie aus dem was sie hören ein
stück weit sind sie auch der pate durch
ihre bemerkung vom letzten wochenende
durch diesen tsunami-alarm mit gewesen
wenn sie das hören macht das nicht
unruhig also zuerst einmal wollte ich
eigentlich vielleicht auch in franken
noch mal besten was der betrieblichen
alltag was testen und so gerne gerade am
mittwoch auch die
arbeitsschutzverordnung noch mal
überarbeitet im kabinett gab mit blick
auf coroner bietet sozusagen im sommer
hat das 1 1 unternehmen die das ehre
auch handhabt im alltag aber unabhängig
davon habe ich gesagt und da teilen wir
ja auch die einschätzung dass masken
draußen also wenn ich gelegentlich hier
in berlin immer noch fahrradfahrer durch
die stadt radeln sehen mit maske auf ist
das okay aber es macht keinen
unterschied
und gerade um akzeptanz hoch zu halten
werde ich ja nur dafür in der zeit mit
niedrigerer instanz wirklich sozusagen
es noch mehr maßzuschneidern weil die
akzeptanz für masken daran ich meine das
kennt jeder aus dem freundeskreis es ist
ja für manche wird das ja irgendwie dann
irgendwann zur glaubensfrage und das
wollten wir vermeiden es hat bis jetzt
ein vorteil in deutschland das anders
als in anderen ländern das tragen von
masken nicht politisiert worden ist wie
wäre es etwa in den vereinigten staaten
gesehen haben zumindest von den meisten
nicht
das heißt aus meiner sicht eben immer
auch angepasst auf die jeweilige
infektions lage mit den maßnahmen
umgehen und sie können natürlich im
landkreis mit einer infektion von 0
über tage nicht die gleichen maßnahmen
implementieren wie in einem landkreis
der 200 hatte oder hat nicht mehr als
gott sei dank einer aber hatte weil das
am ende auch irgendwann akzeptanz kostet
so und deswegen gibt es ja auch die
stufen pläne auf das lka der dazu
vorschläge gemacht es gibt auch
vergleichbare andere ansätze und es gibt
ein paar grundsätze und maske draußen
jedenfalls oder insgesamt draußen ist
das infektionsrisiko deutlich reduziert
außer sie stehen jetzt ganz eng enger
beieinander und es gleichzeitig gibt es
die regel im innenraum umso enger der
raum und und das und umso mehr menschen
drin desto dringlicher ist entweder
verpflichten oder schon aus
eigenverantwortung die maske und das
bleibt eben auch jetzt über den sommer
so und wird auf jeden fall auch für
herbst/winter ein thema auch wieder
füreinander und miteinander sein und
insofern geht es nicht um die wetter her
oder oder oder katastrophen ereignisse
begriffe die sie gerade da verwandt
haben aus meiner sicht sondern eher
darum dass wir die richtige abfolge
finden
auch beim lockern es muss nicht alle
zwei tage einen schritt gegangen wären
wir haben immer dafür geworben die ware
nach zwei drei wochen zu schauen wo wir
stehen und es muss vor allem eine
bereitschaft da sein dafür werde ich in
dem moment wo es wieder hochgeht nicht
erst eingreifen bei 50 im landkreis und
in der stadt nicht warten sondern die
lehre ist doch wirklich möglichst früh
die dinge dann wieder runter zu bringen
und die bereitschaft ist voraussetzung
finde ich für jede lockerung also man
muss wenn man viel lockert auch bereit
sein dann sehr schnell wenn sie es
anders entwickelt auch wieder
einzuschränken
am sonntag wählt fernsehen herr minister
sie haben gerade gesagt nicht warten bis
die inzidenz erst bei 50 ist die antwort
des bundes war ja dann die bundes
notbremse jetzt würde mich mal
interessieren
wie plant man man hat ja jetzt die
komfortable situation dass man noch
etwas zeit hat laut professor wieder
zumindest einige wochen bis die delta
variante dann dominant ist wie laufen da
aktuell in diesen tagen die konkreten
planungen spielt die bundes notbremse in
richtung herbst eine rolle
muss man da noch mal ran gehen weil sich
gewissermaßen die parameter ja auch
verschoben haben man hat deutlich mehr
impfungen wir eine inzidenz betrachtung
oder die hauptsächliche instanz
betrachtung ist ja dann eigentlich nicht
mehr zeitgemäß also zuerst einmal habe
ich sehr dafür geworben das haben wir
auch gemacht dass die bund und länder
bei der gesundheitsministerkonferenz das
thema sorgt e mail server im sommer
recht beim herz sommer und
reiserückkehrer und einreisende und
sommerreisen wir deutlich früher
adressieren ich kann mich noch sehr gut
erinnern letztes jahr wie das thema weil
wir alle nicht damit gerechnet haben
dass bei einem europa das so runter war
insgesamt ist so schnell in bestimmten
regionen wieder hochgeht
das haben wir frühzeitiger gemacht als
letztes jahr auch lesson learned auch
mit den neuen werkzeugen die wir haben
sondern es auch nur vernünftig umsetzen
nicht wenige sagen wir schafft doch
endlich die testpflicht für einreisende
per flugzeug ab nein
ja die inzidenz der meisten länder aus
denen leute kommen ist niedrig aber es
ist jetzt auch eingespielt ist
funktioniert doch gut also behalten wir
es bei gerade auch für diese reise
sorgen dann haben wir das thema herbst
winter an das robert koch institut
gebeten sie arbeiten auch daran schon
mal miteinander zu schauen auch mit
hohen impfquoten mit dem wissen dass wir
zusätzlich haben zu modellieren und die
themen zu definieren um die wir uns
jetzt schon kümmern mit blick auf herbst
und winter uk hatte den titel dazu
preparing for challenging winter ich
suche nach den passenden deutschen titel
der das ähnlich eindrücklich formuliert
aber jedenfalls frühzeitig sich
vorbereiten und wir haben vereinbart wir
sprechen da drüber zeitnah und dann
werden wir das mit anderen experten
institutionen gemeinsam erörtern
in dem prozess von zwei drei vier wochen
und daraus empfehlungen für deutschland
für herbst/winter im sommer schon so
herleiten dass wir dann anschließend mit
den ländern darüber sprechen können
dass das auch alles umgesetzt wird
idealerweise miteinander und dazu
gehören eben auch die fragen was
passiert eigentlich wenn trotz hoher
impfquote instanzen hoch gehen weil es
immer noch einen teil sie hier
großbritannien ungeimpfter gibt welche
folgen etwas welche krankheits lasten
wenn ich diesen begriff benutzen darf
diesen technischen können daraus
überhaupt entstehen es werden ja auch
dann auch bei 20 jährigen gibt es immer
ein anteil der dann auch intensiv
medizin braucht und all das werden wir
modellieren und daraus empfehlungen
ableiten und das ja deutlich früher als
letztes jahr
nachfragen der nachfrage hat so aber die
bundes notbremse als instrument ist auch
nach wie vor möglich auch im herbst nein
die bundes notbremse läuft zum 30 juni
aus aber die kanzlerin hat er gesagt sie
sei auch reaktiviert sie ist ja nur
durch gesetzgeber beschluss reaktiviert
war noch viel besser wäre doch dass wenn
wir den dem modus zurück kommen die
nicht geschrieben habe wir haben
vereinbart schon seit letztem jahr
regional sofort einzuschreiten wenn
inzidenz hochgeht 35 und 50 er ins ident
stehen übrigens über den dreißigsten
sechster hinaus im
infektionsschutzgesetz als auch
richtwerte für maßnahmen und deswegen
habe ich ja dafür dass wir erst gar
nicht wieder in solche incidents bereich
gekommen sondern frühzeitig die dinge
unter kontrolle bringen regional so ich
nehme an dieser stelle zwei fragen
digital zusammen an sie herr franke die
kolleginnen breu von fachmedium
gesundheitspolitischer
informationsdienst fragt einerseits sie
sparen von einer gruppendynamik bei den
impfungen haben sie dabei die
befürchtung wenn der meister die
beschäftigten fragt ob sie sich impfen
lassen wollen dass es umgekehrt zu
diskriminieren diskriminierung am
arbeitsplatz kommen kann wenn sich
jemand nicht impfen lassen bilden für
inwiefern kollidiert das mit fragen nach
dem willen zur impfung durch den meister
nicht mit der ärztlichen schweigepflicht
das ist die eine frage und die andere
frage nämlich noch dazu in den usa
zahlen führen
die kollegin mißlbeck vom ärzte
nachrichtendienst in den usa zahlen
firmen ihren mitarbeitern boni wenn sie
sich impfen lassen ist das auch ein
modell für deutschland also vielleicht
mal zur letzten frage
die impfung ist freiwillig und insofern
wird das auch unter datenschutz
gesichtpunkten so angeboten das also
niemand da irgendwelche repressalien
fürchten muss wenn er eben nicht zum
impfen geht beziehungsweise auch auf der
anderen seite werden wir nicht in
saint-pierre intensivieren wenn jemand
zur impfung geht also dass eine
freiwilliges angebot und diejenigen die
dies annehmen ist gut und wir
akzeptieren aber auch dass es
mitarbeiterinnen oder mitarbeiter gibt
die das nicht annehmen
und da sind wir mit unserer datenschutz
abteilung abgestimmt und haben
entsprechende vorkehrungen auch
getroffen
die frage zu den boden sag ich ja gerade
es gibt keine boni
ok und die gruppendynamik die wählen sie
sozusagen unterschwellig auch nicht
coachen akamai dynamic gibt es immer von
unternehmensseite aus haben wir die
vorkehrungen getroffen dass er auch
niemand diskriminiert wird und das ja
auch die ärztliche schweigepflicht
gerade vor allem eingehalten wird also
das nicht irgendwo medizinische daten da
in umlauf kommen
wenn ich das mal sagen auf diese
gruppendynamik ist aus meiner sicht
gewollt das ist bei allen
präventionsmaßnahmen so präventionen in
der gruppendynamik macht immer mehr
freude als alleine das ist wie sport
treiben
das ist wie sich gesund ernähren ist
auch schöner wenn die gruppe das
gemeinsam macht und der sonst noch
ungesund ist macht vielleicht in der
gruppendynamik mit beim gesund ernähren
weil die anlage ist auch machen und ihn
überzeugen und das gilt bei der
grippeschutzimpfung die im betrieb ja
auch gemacht wird wo ich mir wünsche
wenn es gruppendynamik gibt und das
wünsche ich mir hier auch also wenn ich
will der will nicht aber wenn jemand
sagt okay wenn der kollege macht mache
ich auch und das mich überzeugen das ist
eigentlich der effekt den wir erreichen
wollen durch betriebs impfung aber
vielleicht spannen sie hat mich vorhin
angesprochen was wir denn so
grundsätzlich machen um eben
der pandemie zu begegnen und kann ich
das unterstreichen dass er wieder gesagt
hat das a und o sind schutzmaßnahmen die
basis schutzmaßnahmen da wir bei 77
schutzkonzept entwickelt seit anfang an
was hervorragend funktioniert hat auch
global und uns wunderbar auch durch die
durch die pandemie durch die krise
geführt hat nämlich abstand halten
jene maßnahmen maske tragen und lüften
und wir haben dort technische maßnahmen
eingeführt wir haben organisatorische
maßnahmen eingeführt wie zum beispiel
home office da womöglich da also
mitarbeiter die nicht unbedingt am
arbeitsplatz sein müssen die sind zu
hause und das haben wir schon seit
anbeginn der pandemie so durchgesetzt
und das hat wunderbar funktioniert und
wir können das auch belegen mit sehr
sehr niedrigen fallzahlen
ich würde gerne noch zwei fragen
schaffen was noch zu machen ist dann bin
ich erstmal bei henderson falsche es
geht um die frage ob intensiv
abteilungen künstlich zu niedrige freie
zahlen belegbar betten angegeben haben
mit den effekten dass sie sich dadurch
wenn das stimmt zum einen staatliche
zahlungen eigentlich erschlichen haben
die ihnen nicht zustehen würden
und zum zweiten der öffentlichkeit ein
falsches bild
ein zu dramatisches bild der
tatsächlichen auslastung oder belastung
von intensivstationen entsteht wieder
vor einer woche waren sie noch nicht
informiert über den inhalt eines briefes
in dem das steht das dass er kein im
januar schon geschrieben hat wenn sie
heute etwas dazu sagen wie konkret und
wie richtig ist aus heutiger sicht diese
warnung und herr sparen was ist getan
worden oder wird getragen gegen einen
solchen möglichen messbar
umständliche informationen zwischen es
gibt ein faktenblatt das ja auch beim
bmg auf die website gestellt wurde
doch sind die wesentlichen informationen
enthalten und diese informationen sind
richtig wichtig und ich was ich sagen
kann von seiten des robert koch
instituts wir haben ja neben diesen
eingängen im gehweg ist also neben
diesen daten haben wir sehr viele daten
die habe ich oft hier auch vorgestellt
in der bundespressekonferenz wales
karten testdaten intelligenz daten wir
haben ja unter anderem auch völlig
unabhängig von dem die wie register zum
beispiel das sogenannte micro sari das
ist eine meldesystem wo und eine anzahl
von glaube ich 72 krankenhäusern der
aktuell immer mitteilen wie viele
personen mit schweren atemwegsinfektion
behandelt werden aktuell und wie viel
prozent der personen davon zum beispiel
kobik patienten sind und alle diese
daten zeigen dass die die ideen die das
was dort sich in die register findet
dass das die tatsache die wahrheit in
hohem maße widerspiegelt das heißt also
die daten sind völlig nachvollziehbar
die situation in den krankenhäusern ist
in keinster weise verzerrt nach unseren
informationen und nach den daten die uns
vorliegen also ich kann grundsätzlich
nicht ausschließen dass es auch falsche
meldung gegeben hat andersrum haben
haben wir jenseits von vermutungen bis
jetzt auch wenig stichhaltigen nachweise
dafür also es ist ja eine debatte und
das sagt im übrigen auch der zitierte
brief das ist die vermutung gibt und in
dem brief heißt es sogar ausdrücklich
dass das aber aus den eigenen daten und
analysen nicht zu erkennen ist
und das ist ja das herausfordernde
insgesamt ich meine auch damals noch mal
zurückschauen ich will dass weil sich
das vorhin sagten
in der bei der anderen frei der kollege
ich sag doch nicht dass alles perfekt
gelaufen ist dass der keiner aber sie
müssen auch dabei
schwierig ist einfach mal schauen es gab
in der ganzen bundesrepublik und
übrigens bells richtigen gang in ganz
europa nicht ein intensivbetten register
keiner wusste wie viele intensivbetten
das eigentlich deutschland wie für
europa zumal wer kein staatliches system
sind also in uk sind alle krankenhäuser
mehr oder weniger vom vereinigten
königreich selbst betrieben dass der
gesundheitsminister der chef aller
krankenhäuser und beschäftigten
das haben wir hier wie ich finde
richtiger weise bei uns nicht
das heißt aber eben gleichzeitig dass
wir die daten wenn wir sie nicht so
zusagen verpflichten zusammenführen
nicht haben und das haben wir sehr
schnell gemacht in dieser pandemie das
register aufgebaut verpflichtend gemacht
verordnungen gemacht ist
weiterentwickelt und das gibt uns jetzt
ein überblick wie wir ihn vorher noch
nie hatten
es ist deswegen schon perfekt nein das
ist deutlich mehr als wir vorhatten
er ist derzeit zweiter teil gibt es zwei
blickwinkel das eine ist die frage der
belastung und das andere ist die
freiheit der cup noch freien kapazitäten
und eine ich kenne jedenfalls niemanden
der in frage gestellt die tatsächliche
belastung dass also die
behandlungszahlen die gemeldet worden
sind auch die tatsächlichen täglichen
ist zahlen an behandlungen sind von 19
patienten auf den unterschiedlichen
intensiv bereichen bis hin zur ecke
und wer mit pflegekräften und intensiv
pflegekräften redet charité ist da vorne
da liegen übrigens an der ecke also an
der schwersten form der behandlungs
notwendigkeit wenn ich es richtig weiß
immer noch 30 40 patienten die um ihr
leben ringen was eine sehr sehr große
zahl das für behandlungen müssen wir
darüber gehen welche belastung da war
und ist teilweise noch an seiner klinik
wieder charité in der behandlung von
cobit 19 patienten bei der meldung der
freien kapazitäten haben wir in dem
moment wo es die vermutung gab sind wir
auf die länder zugegangen und auf die
krankenhäuser mit der aufforderung
bestmögliche
meldungen auch sicherzustellen und
natürlich wahrheitsgemäße angaben
sicherzustellen das ist ja das
entscheidende das ist für mich dann auch
eine frage das würde ich auch mal sagen
von medizinischen und ärztlichen ethos
was ich melde oder nicht melde als
intensivmediziner in ein register ist ja
die frage irgendwann wohl wo können sie
überhaupt irgendwann noch unterstellen
dass die dinge korrekt gemacht werden
also einerseits ich weiß noch die ganze
republik hätte man gesagt im bürokratie
und zu viele regeln und wir stehen uns
selbst im weg und die ärzteschaft hat
gesagt wenn wir jetzt noch dokumentieren
sollen ob es eine vorerkrankung gibt bei
der info gleichzeitig war es beim
intensiv register aus so dass dann am
ende irgendwann die frage ist auf wen
können wir uns ja noch verlassen und ich
habe erst mal ein grundvertrauen den
ärztinnen und ärzte also wenn wir nicht
mehr dieses grundvertrauen haben in
bestimmte heilberufe dann steht aber
irgendwie noch deutlich mehr in frage
und deswegen muss das aufgeklärt werden
da bin ich absolut dabei und was ich im
beitrag den wir leisten können leisten
wir im übrigen auch seit januar in
kontakt mit den mit den ländern aber es
muss gleichzeitig auch von der anderen
seite jenseits von vermutungen dann
gearbeitet werden und da ist auch viel
vermutungen im raum und ich habe
momentan den eindruck dass auch ist
gelegentlich droht wie bei der masken
frage jetzt meine ich die frage trägt
man maske oder nicht wie hältst du es
mit den intensivbetten wie hältst du es
mit den masten
das wären ja irgendwann sehr polit
politisierte fragen und du hast keine
chance mehr auf die fachliche debatte
und wir müssen sehr aufpassen das ist ja
auch passiert denn eins haben wir
geschafft
anders als in fast allen unseren
europäischen nachbarländern war das
deutsche gesundheitswesen zu keinem
zeitpunkt so überlastet dass nicht mehr
alle behandelt werden können
pflegekräfte waren stark belastet und
teilweise und da kann man nur dankbar
sein für ein einsatz auch überlastet
aber das system insgesamt hat was
leisten können was weniger an regus und
heizsysteme auf der welt geschafft haben
dann hat die letzte abschließende frage
herr jung von der augsburger album
er fragt am sicher sparen zu masken auf
erde treffen bericht dazu und auch sie
anfang juni von ermittlern aus bayern
zum masten affäre um die orte müssten
befragt worden sind und hatten sie
kenntnis dass herr ist leider im kontakt
zum bundesgesundheitsministeriums eigene
geschäftsinteressen vertritt also
provision für die vermittlung erhält für
die vermittlung erhält die erste frage
kann ich mit ja beantworten und die
zweite mit nein
gut dann mit dieser knappen antwort
wollen wir es bewenden lassen vielen
dank das sind viele fragen digital offen
geblieben aber sie haben gesehen dass
die zeit trotzdem erschöpft ist bitte um
ihr verständnis und einen schönen tag
noch
dankeschön